hello everyone it's really a great
pleasure to be here today and in such
distinguished company and so we're going
to to hear from the most recent Canada
Safari a chairs who work in
reinforcement learning it's the field
where I spend most of my time so I'm
very excited to hear what they have to
say and so what we're gonna do first of
all is I ask everybody to introduce
themselves and tell us a little bit
about their research in reinforcement
learning and just more broadly and we'll
start with charbon probably right
so I already did my introduction has to
decide who knows probably people
remember that I work in reinforcement
learning and theory and very happy to be
here and I'd be curious about what
questions you guys are going to have
hello everyone so I'm Jung Yu I'm from
University of Waterloo and the vector
means to do my main area of research is
doing machine optimization for machine
learning where we look at different
first-order creating algorithms how do
we efficiently implement them when we
have some structure in the problem and
how do we provide surrett guarantees
when we deploy the algorithm in a
dispute environment another interest
that I built in the past few years is
about deep generative models where I'm
fascinated by the interplay between many
ideas from you know a number of fields
for instance we have probability
inference we have deep learning we have
statistics probability and optimal
transport all these great ideas that you
can find in in deep gentle models yeah
so I'm very happy to be here thank you
hi I'm Sheila McElrath I'm a professor
in the computer science department at
the University of Toronto and I'm also a
member of the vector Institute my my
research has historically looked at at
deliberative reasoning tasks what you
can think of as as thinking tasks I
guess and largely at sequential
decision-making tasks well more recently
I've been focusing more on reinforcement
learning and
really trying to understand we're
symbolic and sub symbol ik reasoning can
come together relooking at some of the
the problems that we've looked at
historically through the through the
lens of logic and probability and models
but now looking at it and new with
through the lens of perception and deep
learning but bringing to bear I think a
lot of the the interesting ideas and
from from symbolic reasoning I'm Nicola
I'm research at Google brain and also
the drunks at at Mila most of my work is
an optimization but I guess they're
already seven chairs in the foundations
of core eval so I ended up in do a
reinforcement learning panel I think
similar to what Courtney said at some
point the optimization for the sake of
optimizations started to bore me a
little bit and so now I'm moving toward
understanding reinforcement learning
from the perspective of optimization
like when we talk about exploration and
reinforcement learning what does that
mean from an optimization perspective I
think funnel me to fundamentally what
interests me is how can we learn with
fewer samples there are many directions
to approach this problem middle learning
is one of them transfer learning but one
of the idea that I worked on I want to
pursue as this idea dance when you see a
sample how much information can you
extract from that sample and right now
we're extremely wasteful we basically
compute the small gradients move in and
we throw that sample away and I believe
that there's much more information we
can gather from it and how to do this
efficiently is part of my research my
name is Jacob Foster and I'm corny at
Facebook I research in California I'll
be starting at Toronto the direct
Institute in the fall of 2020 and I can
be driven by the question how can we do
machine learning in a world that
contains other learning agents so
obviously when we do reinforcement we
typically assume that the environment is
static so the agent can interact with
this environment over and over and over
again to learn optimal policy but
clearly the moment we deploy anything in
the real world the real world contains
other learning agents those could be the
human users those could be other
learning agents that coexist in the same
environment think for example about
self-driving cars and the presence of
other
agents fundamentally changes the kind of
problem we're facing so this for example
is a fast multi agent problem we all
hear in communicating we're thinking
about the intents and points of views of
others and we're trying to coordinate
and collaborate and I'm thinking about
how we can bring those capabilities that
are so key for allowing agents to
cooperate in large numbers to machine
learning algorithms and I've studied
this using deep multi age reinforcement
learning where both developed new
benchmarks to also think about new
learning algorithms and I'm really
excited to pursue that agenda at Toronto
hello Hey so my name is P Alec back home
I'm a new assistant professor at curious
Montreal with it affiliated with Miele
I've been working for the past few years
on the problem of temporal abstraction
in reinforcement learning actually been
working with Dana here who is my advisor
during my PhD
generally speaking I'd say I'm
interested about the the grand challenge
in machine learning which is that of
learning of our long horizon so that
goes back to the question of credit
assignment at the really high level and
I'm interested to tackle that question
from let's say a representation learning
point of view first but I'm also very
interested in looking at for relations
of that problem that are routed into
optimization methods and in particular
I'm interested at the interface of
optimization and automatic
differentiation methods which are so
important for us in our field in deep
learning so these are the things I was
working on and that's what I keep doing
right now and especially these days I'm
missing some interest about by level and
higher collectivization formulations
which are really useful when it comes to
talking about meta learning so that's
where I'm hoping to go over the next
couple of years thank you very much and
so I have a question for the people who
are new to the Canadian academic system
so new recruits that includes each other
and why Canada oh why did you choose to
join academic institutions in Canada
anybody can start like Diwali I'm
looking for volunteers thank you
new recruits for this one so I've been
away from Canada for not long so I was
it was just a way for a year and a half
but still and made me realize that we
really had a unique environment in
Montreal at least when I left the way
that the research was conducted was very
much organic I felt and that was part I
was due to how much people would talk to
each other from different fields it was
quite amazing that by the time I was I
was made McGill basically we had like
contractions with what Yahshua's lab and
University of Montreal in that that
cross interaction really led to entereth
to interesting ideas and that's
something I really miss and I really am
looking forward to see again I think
yoshua likes that to say that research
is it's a bit like taking a random walk
when in tuition it's something that
belief as well and I think we're really
lucky that in Montreal in probably in
Canada in general we're allowed to do
that sort of research to just think here
about things to just dream and and and
come up with new ideas in a very
creative manner so so we can't really I
think we can't really do research having
in mind some kind of business mindset I
don't think that's how research goes and
I think we have the right environment to
conduct research back home if I can just
add to that I think sort of in
reinforcement we think about the horizon
gamma right so how short-term or
long-term are you thinking about this
problem and I think the best research
comes out of extremely long-term
thinking but that's also the hardest
research to find support and funding for
because returns for this if you have
gamma equals zero point nine nine nine
nine nine you know this might not come
through for the next 10 20 years and at
least historically Khanna's had this
track record of supporting researchers
that work on things which don't actually
right now work on the leading regime and
you know if you listen to what I just
said about my research agenda these
agents have learned to interact with
others in the count for humans and the
environment and self-driving cars and
theory of mind that's not going to be in
a product next year the year after so I
think it's really maintaining this
ability to explore a large number of
diverse and potentially groundbreaking
research directions which Canada has
been doing in the past which I hope to
be able to take part of in the future
and then there's the obvious answers
around the fantastic talent and the
collaborative nature of research in the
Canadian ecosystem which has brought me
to Canada yeah like I'm just very
thankful for Canada I'm coming from
under originally and I arrived to this
country like 13 years ago
and I had the most amazing pleasant
experience and I think my family right
those things that we are Canadians we
tried it for him and like we learned a
lot and yeah like this disc is really
amazing very welcoming and I think we
should keep it like that and that's
that's very important everything else
that was said curiosity driven research
quality I think it applies probably
across all Canada I experienced
personally that and that went on but but
my colleagues are telling me that it's
it's kind of like a characteristics of
this nation and like we have to cherish
this and and it's it's really wonderful
to have a country in the world which
operates this way it's it's truly
amazing
Nicola you're basically a Google brain
down the hallway you chose to also spend
time in the academic context can you
tell us a little bit why why that's
important to you
I can I need to choose my words
carefully I think industry provides a
lot of tools provides a lot of compute
provides a lot of very senior
researchers but if some reason for the
reason companies are built there are
very few people with free time in
industry mostly students people who are
eager to learn and they want to try
stuff and they take the time to learn
stuff in an industry you're evaluated
regularly and you might not care about
it but at the end of the day you still
feel like you have to you have to
produce and I think Miele offers a an
environment where you have many many
students who don't operate on the same
time scale so most of the senior
researchers in this room operate on a
longer time scale because they've you
know they've achieved what they want you
to achieve another can think but junior
researcher in the industry I think
operates in a much shorter time scale
but students still operate on the three
four five year that the length of do PhD
and so being at Miele allows me to be
surrounded by these people who still
take the time to think with what I want
to achieve several years from now which
is not as easy in industry also
everyone's always very busy in the
industry like you come someone say can
we talk they say maybe next Thursday it
was something that doesn't happen at at
Mila and Sheila and maybe you want to
tell us a little bit about how you see
the evolution in the Canadian AI
ecosystem during that time that you've
been here so I can start so I guess when
when AI has chant I've been in in in an
academic position in Canada I guess
since 2004 so a long time and I've
certainly seen things change a lot
during that time both in terms of the
types of questions that people are
addressing and also in in terms of the
population of people who are doing that
type of work one thing I wanted to say
though is that that I think that the the
the pan-canadian AI strategy has been
very interesting model for funding I've
been in Canada for a long time and of
course I've seen the Canadian government
fund a lot of industry to come and set
up shop in Canada they'll give
incentives to industry to come and and
and set up an office but what was so
what's so brilliant about this program
is that the money went to the
researchers the money went to do
fundamental research and as a
consequence all these industries came
and if I think about what's changed a
lot in in the last five years at least
with actually I think as a consequence
of the pen Canadian AI strategy has been
this influx of interest and and
companies coming to Canada but to
participate in this activity because of
the the hype and the sense that there's
a lot going on here and that we have the
best students and the best research
going on in the world so I think that's
been something that's really exciting
yeah yeah I agree with everything you
just said and so I already did my
studies in University of Alberta and
then I went away for a little while and
then come back to : and what makes me a
lot is the continuing investment of the
Canadian government of the Canadian
business on the general area of
artificial intelligence and we have a
number of amazing people working in this
area probably the most dominant in the
world and we have a large number of
students who are studying at different
universities and the three Institute's
we have yeah I'm super excited about the
the the stage we are at now and I think
we all need to thank CFR for making
these are happening okay thank you so
let's talk a little bit about research
reinforcement learning is very hot
fields lots of publications lots of
interesting things going on it would be
nice to hear from each of you about one
specific piece of work that is let's say
from the last five years but very not
necessarily very very recent but can be
very recent can be from you can be from
somebody else that that you really like
and would like to to share with us and
we can start with kindergarten just
gonna say
setting over the last months or a couple
of years I think there's been quite a
lot of interest in reinforcement
learning to bring more methods from the
control theory side and I think I'm very
excited about this too one reason is
I've always been curious about
continuous time formulations and I think
it's a very natural framework to talk
about this in parallel to this there's
also been a lot of interest in now the
neural OD'ing so all these things kind
of fit really well together and it has
strong roots into control theory so I
think in reinforcement learning we can
learn a lot from these methods but of
course there are still challenges that
need to be addressed in control theory
and I think we have some expertise in
reinforcement learning we can make a
difference for that so in particular
when it comes to a problem of system
identification and finding in learning
models and all those models which
probably were gonna parameterize with
deep Nets I think we can do quite a can
have quite of an impact so I'm pretty
excited about learning about these
things these days and I'm generally
going to be looking forward to apply
more of this over the next next couple
years and the second thing which I've
been quite excited about I've mentioned
it is that body of work on article
optimization which has been there for a
long time so I think are called
optimization particular by level
optimization gives us really strong
foundations to talk about meta learning
and reform and learning in particular
and we have lots of experts actually
around that we can find some thinking at
Universal Montreal we have experienced
I'm thinking of Emma fridging girl for
example who've been applying these
techniques for a while perfect for to
predict patterns in transportation
networks for a long time for example
it's just that they don't call it
inverse reinforcement learning but
that's essentially what they do so I
think there's a lot of tools that we can
learn from other fields and and bring
this back into our field and come up
with better and stronger methods so I'm
gonna follow that same kind of pattern
of thought I think the division between
the different fields we have so thinking
about optimal control search planning
and learning reinforcement as being
different fields I think that's been a
huge detriment to the progress across
these different fields so you just spoke
about optimal control and reinforcement
breaking down that boundary I think what
we've observed in the last
couple of years or so is that the
barrier between search and learning has
been coming down and I think that's a
great thing I think we have to start
thinking about methods that combine all
of these ideas to tackle how we can make
decisions in a sequential manner and in
particular in this line of work I think
mu0
the recent result from deep mind that
showed how we can do implicit planning
inside the learning context combined
with search is a very promising
direction because I think if we really
want to have systems that can learn to
generalize to new settings
we can't just pre compute every single
answer to every possible problem we
might ever have we have to be able to
think on the fly and plan on the spot in
order to generalize to new situations
and I believe this is sort of a trend
that will continue observing in the next
three years we're thinking holistically
about decision making rather than finger
what this is what I do this is what you
do and I think that's really good being
at a conference like Europe's where
there are representatives from all these
different subfields and hopefully there
will be these dialogues that can start
off the new collaborations in these
directions in particular for the future
I'm excited to bring those same ideas to
multi-agent learning because when we're
sitting when we're interacting and mood
in groups of agents we naturally have to
think about the points of use of other
agents in the in in the environment and
that's very compatible with the
model-based approach yeah it's kind of
hard to follow ever after these
insightful answers I think mine's gonna
be much more naive so one is to
basically throw up the interaction
between again optimization reinforcement
learning the reinforcement learning
community used to be very isolated I
remember these workshops was ten people
in a room 15 years ago and the same ten
every single time and I think they've
really they're really open up and now
there's a whole bunch of people trying
to the Cynara from an optimization
perspective bringing what does what does
it do what is this loss function how can
we change it what are the consequences
and I think there's really a lot of
insights that have been have been gained
from this cross-pollination within
optimization and RL the other one I
think is exciting is the link between
optimization than Gentiles
so there was a question that the first
panel optimization people used to think
that there's a loss function I want to
minimize and I don't care about the rest
and it's up to you to design a
regularizer such that if I minimize this
it's going to generalize well and we
realize there are many many more links
between the two and so understand this
mechanism there's a lot of work that
came out of TTI but also other groups
about how can the optimization effects
generalization and what do you want what
do you look for and I think that's
really interesting especially again
coming back to RL the concept of
generalization in RL everyone talks
about it no one does it no one
understands what it means and that's my
understanding and and so I think there's
there's really something to be done here
to understand where generalization comes
from what it means and how can we when
we train our models we can affect
generalization so I I would echo a lot
of the things that Jacob said actually I
think one of the things that really
excites me is this this convergence of
representation and search and and and re
and learning all together and I think it
one great example of that is in DB mu mu
zero the other thing that that and I
think that that's going to be a way for
it related to that I guess on the
representation front the other thing
that I think is is really exciting is
the the prevalence of language in
reinforcement learning now we see that
with Jacob Andreas's work and and with
with some of the other more recent works
where language human language provides
this wonderful abstraction for how we
think about the world a very purposeful
abstraction we use language to to
communicate with each other to think
about the world we use it to communicate
with with with computer programs we are
with computer with computers and we also
use it even just to think about
mathematics that's just another language
another abstraction we use to make sense
of the world and I think we're seeing
more and more in reinforcement learning
the use of natural languages or
programming languages as useful
abstractions for conveying rewards for
understanding causal models or
representations and I think that's going
to be a very profitable area of research
going forward
yeah as for me I'm reading tricked by
the recent development in genitive
models on mobile in the density
estimation problem so I just came back
from a difference last week and when I
talked to my statistic friends and they
were puzzled like why are you working on
density estimation this has been studied
like for so many many years instead it's
all very well known but then if you
start to think about what we do in
density estimation you estimate you
spend lots of lots of time and effort
estimating in estimating a density
function and then when can't done to you
the inference that you want to fail
marginalize the density we want to do
some conditioning on the density
function suddenly becomes very very
challenge again and inserting
applications we want to have to learn a
density function that you can easily do
samples from this is where the huge
generative models are very powerful at
but then if you want to have a massive
like and you know both that are both
easy to you only have a message that can
be you can do the inference easily and
you can also choose samples easily then
suddenly to my knowledge is not many
message that can give you that and and
the other in the interesting thing I
observed in this field is we are so
obsessed with density functions one when
we asked anyone about a probability
function at the artists future and the
first thing that came in mind is the
density function but there are many many
different ways that can uniquely
characterize the distribution and in
fact in the seven days where I mean a
person has done some work on he has been
advocating on using condyle functions
for instance to do statistical modeling
and I think many of these recent
generative models are exactly doing that
right how do we learn a concave function
but in a multivariate setting so this is
what interests me are not right so I
it's interesting to have I guess I have
some perspective of what was going on
raised for reinforcement learning and
talking about the days when there were
ten people in the room and maybe one I
was one of them
and Senator one of them and and it will
of the days but it's really good to have
all of you here and and it makes the
field more exciting to work in and to
have these different perspectives coming
in and so one of the the things that I'm
really excited about in connection there
to this is is this optimization
viewpoint reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning you can formulate
it as an optimization problem it's that
like that's the definition of it it's a
weird optimization problem though right
you want to maximize the return in every
at every state if you are in in this MVP
word which is like a market here in
optimization and if you try to merge
this with generalization suddenly you
see that like you can't do this any
worse you have to somehow sacrifice your
original objective and know maybe you
change your objective and you find that
even the new objective is difficult to
optimize so there are very interesting
questions around how can we efficiently
optimize objectives or the objective
that you choose at the end because these
problems I just have too many variables
and like if you write it as a
constrained optimization problem too
many constraints so the question is what
are you going to do about this but the
standard answer from CS is that you have
to solve some relaxed problem and then
you can try to look for tools for doing
that but until quite recently and not
many people care that much about this
perspective I mean like during the many
years time to time there were some
isolated attempts to use this approach
but there was no you know like
significant effort like a bigger
community caring about this problem so I
feel that like this these times are
really exciting because we have these
influx of great new minds who are
excited about our field and I expect to
see many wonderful new reason
I I could call it a bunch of papers that
I'm excited about in connection today is
like people are discovering these days
that for example if you somehow like
make assumptions about different
assumption people do make different
assumptions in reinforcement learning of
what can you represent is there like a
BYU functions or policies or occupancy
measures or maybe the model and and
people find big differences in terms of
what these assumptions mean and it's
like really interesting place for a
terrace to be because you want to you
know categorize and understand how these
assumptions relate to each other some
really excited about this thank you so
reinforcement learning is very prominent
partly because it's now able to solve
larger problems and I think a lot of us
are also excited about potential
applications but a lot of the stuff that
you see currently as applications of
reinforcement learning are games and
then in terms of value function
estimation and learning algorithms there
has been some success in in neuroscience
in terms of modeling and so one of the
things that I'm curious about I'd like
to hear from the panel is either what is
the application area that you would be
most excited about that you think would
be really good for reinforcement
learning to be in and make an impact or
what is a problem in reinforcement
learning that we really need to solve in
order for it to become impactful in in
practice and I will go in random order
for this one and whoever speaks can't
say what somebody else said already so I
want to get six different things here so
I'd like to start okay
so I'll answer the second question
because I have no clue but the first one
to either two things that we could be
much better that's the first one again
it's a personal bias its reusing past
trajectories so some people have
collected
trajectory is using maybe different
policies or even in slightly different
environments since we're talking about
generalization how do we use these and
we tend to be extremely bad and off
policy is really the stuff we do when we
have no other choice but I think there's
so much to be learned from from these
trajectories and so it comes back to
what is saying at the very beginning
which is we extract I think very little
information from our experience and we
should be able to extract much much more
the other aspects I think that we could
do and I made everyone at my table
suffer was pictures on my kid I just had
a kid and this idea that you don't need
a reward to learn about the world and I
think right now reinforcement learning
is not very good at this at
understanding and creating a
representation of the world without
having a specific objective in mind so
we can you know put in some inductive
bias and say that's what the
representation should be but just
exploring the world what is the proper
exploration mechanism I think it would
be great to have something along these
lines
so off-ball if you're learning and no
reward learning to summarize okay I will
just add that a little bit so I think
they so they can net a point here to be
made so what is the reward incentivizes
researchers and machine learning and
that's commonly being able to
demonstrate that your method
accomplishes something amazing that
wasn't done before comedy this is done
through benchmark environments or state
of the art and I think this has been
driving sort of the focus of
reinforcement learning in games so I
think what we're missing
systematically our benchmark
environments that are still tractable we
can make progress now but that are
closer to the kind of problems we hope
to address in the real world right so
for example I study this question of
theory of mind and I currently address
this in a card game Hanavi this isn't
because I think the card game is super
practically relevant but it's because I
can study how agents can learn to
interpret the actions of others and
reason over intent and partial
observability in this card game setting
what we don't have is a simulator that
does the high-level components of
self-drive which have the same
challenges but lets us address them and
tackle these questions in a way that
don't have to go and interact with the
real world right now because the
questions that are limiting progress of
reinforcement learning sample complexity
robustness reliability those just aren't
as relevant in the games benchmarks that
we use currently so I think as a figure
it's really important to think about
what are those big application areas
that we want to see progress in in 5-10
years and what are the simulation
environments that we can develop as
benchmarks today that will actually
encourage research in these critical
directions so I guess instead of
answering the question I'm posing three
more questions with my answer but the
upshot of it is benchmarks its
benchmarks which are targeted towards
real-world problems rather than
benchmarks for the sake of showing
superhuman performance in a game let's
show good performance in a relevant task
rather than superconn performance in a
potentially less relevant task I guess
there are lots of different interesting
challenge problems but when one that I'd
like to focus on I guess is task ability
so I think that the we now we we incent
reinforcement learning systems by
defining reward functions which are
mappings from States or states and
actions and States to some sort of a
number but but if you think about a lot
of the classical work on AI planning or
in robotics we want to be able to tell
our agent what we want it to be able to
do and and it should be able to to
figure out how to do it with it not
necessarily by by learning from scratch
all over again and so I think tasks
ability is a really important problem
and I think it's one that's been
addressed by the classical or the his
the go fight planning community but
what's interesting that the go fight
planning community does not know how to
do is how to do the low-level control
issue so for example I can plan I'm sure
all of us or could imagine writing a
program to plan to get from where we are
today to our hotel room for example but
to understand how to move your joints to
get off of this chair or to to pick up a
cup those are things that reinforcement
learning is very very good at those
those low-level skills that require some
sort of adaptive
experience over time and so I think some
sort of combination of the two is is a
fruitful place to to look for for
research in the near future thank you so
high-level and low-level interplay oh
yeah so it's a timing and ro yeah and
tasks a bit with instability perfect and
generalization task ability and
generalization I think are you so I
think I'm going to answer your question
more on the practical side this is
something more that I would liked to
work on or the next years I think
there's a there's a lot of potential
potential for applying reinforcement
learning methods and control methods for
computational sustainability and climate
change questions so it's not something I
have expertise in these topics but I'm
hoping at least to find collaborators to
work on these questions a bit more
closely
one reason is I think that all of us are
aware that climate change is something
we need to tackle quite I mean quite
soon but from a research point of view I
think these problems also very
interesting because of their structure
oftentimes when we think about you know
natural system it involves some kind of
dynamical systems when you talk about
dynamical systems you might also think
about you know all these then could you
use time formulations which are things
that I find interesting these days so
it's something that I'm looking forward
to work more on but once again I am
there's a need for collaboration to do
these things to find these interesting
problems but being in Canada I don't
think it's gonna be that difficult to
find these problems because of our
natural resources I think there are many
problems such as optimal optimal
management of Fisheries for example is a
classic one which which we can do
sequential decision making there are
also lots of potentially very impactful
application for better control system
for things boring things like HVAC so
all things you know air and temperature
control and buildings these things can
be automated can make a big difference
if we can have better control over the
energy usage so these are all
applications that I'm excited about and
I think that could have a huge impact in
the
five years also wonderful thank you I've
been trying to think hard about and the
reinforce of money I've learned from
this man here so one thing I remember is
an agree with Nicola on the earth policy
importance of warning of policy learning
so one thing I remember is one of the
first few sound of policy learning
algorithms that have been developed in
the in the IOA our lab at university
warden airport is that they're still
complicated that you have to employ two
time scales and if you look at the proof
it's extremely extremely complicated
mostly by this man here and and the the
techniques if you look at the techniques
you use they use all the yeast and but
one thing i think it will be great if we
can naturally simplify these analysis of
this ends and and i think there's a
great hope here because the early
approach has been very popular in the
machine learning community for instance
we have the OD approach phone you know
the answer destination we have people
have used ODU to analyze some deep
architectures right so i think there's a
lot of promising questions in how do we
simplify part of policy learning
algorithms thank you can't disagree
sorry
yeah I'm not sure how complicated that
analysis is though but we can imagine
yeah like would be nice but it's true
that there is a lot lot left to be done
you know policy learning just to mention
like even for Bennett's like you know
like I'd like to study the simplest
setting in which you already find some
gap in your knowledge and that often
leads to ban it and it's ridiculous but
that there's the trees and so already in
Bennett's if you have a batch of data
then we don't know what is a minimax
optimal aggregate on T to estimate like
okay it's a a little bit more
complicated
just minimax optimum it's often Aveeno
about like in sneering instance often
our atoms we usually do have that and
then that means that we do understand
how to adapt to the particular instance
that you're learning on and just the
fact that in or it in banos we don't
have this shows that we need more more
people looking at these problems so of
policy learning definitely agree at the
risk of repeating myself and in
designing algorithms that scale
computationally efficient sample
efficient and can be always live state
action spaces we have those in very few
corner cases and I see that like these
are important because you're going to
build on the top of these right so there
are so many other issues that you you
also want to address we heard about very
long time scales so maybe that brings up
temporary abstraction because maybe
function approximation can be viewed as
doing spatial abstraction but maybe you
want to do action and ten perhaps action
but if you don't have foundations to
gonna and so all those argot terms that
people try to use our you know like it
just like shaky foundations it's not
going to fly so sometimes we need to go
back to these simpler problem settings
and then find those gaps and work on
those gaps and expiration was mentioning
connection to having no reward but I
don't know like I'm going back and forth
between these two views even if you do
have the reward and you rarely see the
reward and you're kind of like already
solving and no reward problem there the
reward is so rarely seen so if you want
to claim that you made progress and
optimizing some reward by learning
online in some big environment then like
you're already addressing the problem of
learning in the face of no reward
because maybe the environment is such
that you will only see the reward after
a long long period
time and what are you gonna do in the
meanwhile but nevertheless this problem
is well it has been occupying me for a
decade or so but again in a simpler
setting because you know like this
complicated things are just too complex
so start with something simple and then
grow from there but yeah like
exploration is is something that
together with functional approximation
and the scarab are atoms it remains a
big open problem and a huge challenge
for the finale thank you very much so
now we have our list of open problems
for reinforcement learning courtesy of
our new co-chairs nine five years we get
back together and it'll all be solved
maybe for this we have made good
progress and I would like to open the
floor up for questions there's a couple
of mics in the back of the room if
people would have any questions or I
suppose you can also shout it out better
to use the mic
hello my name is David and I just wanted
because one of you mentioned the
relevance of having suitable environment
to test our models with respect to the
applications within which we're going to
apply them and I was thinking yes in the
world sometimes we have we do we
supposed to work in continuous time so
having contains a continuous time models
would be appropriate and also the right
environment to evaluate them but I was
thinking I also thought about fact that
recently I don't remember that anyone
has been focusing on real time
interactions mostly within the framework
of RL we assume that we can stop the
environment and it unsane command - it
was in the real time which one B would
won't have to deploy their model and the
problem in fact would not be you might
have fullness in which you have a
synchrony between your environment and
your model I encountered that during an
internship and it sort of made me I mean
I wonder do you think that this would be
interesting to explore in the future
base mode I mean context in which you
have a synchrony between new
environments and new agent so I guess I
mentioned the benchmarks in the
environment and I think what you're
saying is a great example right so as a
researcher as long as we stay within
these game environments with full
control of the step function we can call
it whenever we're ready you may never
have thought about the fact that real
world progresses even while I'm sitting
here thinking about my answer to your
question right and it's exactly this
kind of problem which I think requires
us to start thinking more about not what
we're going to solve in the next year
but we're reinforced running could
actually be useful in five years time
ten years time and start talking to
application areas and then start
developing benchmarks environments that
do include this question of
synchronicity where you know the
information comes in that the continuous
in a continuous time where actions can
be taken in a continuous time right so I
think these are exactly the questions
that are relevant
and I can't think of a standard
benchmark environments in reinforcement
in right now that I even near those kind
of problems
yes so if I can just add a little bit on
this I think they are benchmarks not
exactly in our community but I think the
gold standard for this is robotics and
we have our colleagues around work on
the robotics and these are in inherently
a synchronous system when they send a
command to the robot arm
robot arm keeps on you know moving at
different time scale everything is like
natural time scale and I think they have
to deal with these questions so I think
we have great a lot of things that we
can learn also from from these
communities and robotics and control
where real time is often time something
that that is inherently like important
okay thank you Chris okay so I hope this
is not too pointed of a question because
I want an answer for myself as well but
I guess this is this is for Csaba
and Jacob in particular so when we think
about picking either models that are
simple on which we can have some sort of
theoretical grasp or when we pick
benchmarks where we can actually start
working and evaluating things how do we
avoid the trap of picking ones that we
already can solve and that might not
generalize to the more interesting
settings that we actually cared about
you know everyone who tries to prove
things knows that often you start with a
smaller set of assumptions and you you
go until you hit a wall and then you put
the wall into your assumptions and
similarly with benchmarks we can often
sort of over fit to that specific thing
without realizing that we weren't
actually generalizing to the full
problem we cared about I do have a short
answer just be honest the scientists and
be very clear about the limitations of
what you're doing and always keep these
in mind and say I don't think it's very
complicated I have a slightly longer
answer obviously I stand by being honest
I think that's always really
but also I like to do work which
encompasses both is simple to example we
can show that the method works in
principle and can be easily on a student
rep reduced and then also show that it
scales to a large benchmark problem and
the the comment I was trying to make
about the issue I find with our current
benchmark problems is which I don't I
don't see them as a stepping stone
towards real-world problems and I am
actually ok if you over fit on a problem
as long as I promise something that we
care about as humanity in the real world
if you get really good at solving
climate change
I'm ok if you can't also tie my
shoelaces right as long as you solve
climate change for me that's fine so I
think the issue of sort of like opening
reinforcement is just that we happen to
optimize and objectives that we don't
actually commonly care about so it's
time for I start thinking more about how
we can align the kind of tasks that
we're solving in simulation to test our
methods were the kind of problems that
we actually care about as society as
humans and then obviously within that
there will be questions like all we have
to truly generalize right what does that
mean you can never interact with the
same environment twice every time you go
and you know called reset it's gonna be
a slightly different world you interact
in it's going to be asynchronous it's
going to have a lot of other interacting
agents and all the other issues that the
real world has which don't currently
reflect within our benchmarking
environments but I think there's a lot
of open work open questions around what
those benchmarks are and how we can
actually evaluate our methods truly and
accurately in them
always keep in mind that we need to be
honest when we do so ok and we have time
for one last question I try to make this
count
so in reinforcement learning we sort of
have an understanding of for example MD
B's right that's a formalization of
reinforcement learning but a lot of
these problems that we are talking about
like exploration or no reward learning
or generalization we don't really have a
formal formalism for what we are trying
to do and as a result when I see
different people now but I talk about
exploration they are talking about
different things right and I don't
understand how we are going to formalize
these problems because we don't like we
have an intuition of what they mean but
we don't quite have a mathematical
formalism about it
accomplished so where do you see formal
formalization along the path of solving
these problems like don't we need to
figure out what the problems are first
precisely mmm not sure whether by the
way Russian is my students so we have we
could have this private discussion as
now I think we had discussions about
this but I think that like I would push
back a little bit of saying that we
don't have the formalisms I think we do
have the formalisms maybe they're a
little bit buried in the theory papers
that people don't necessarily that often
read and maybe the theory papers are to
be blamed because maybe they're not as
accessible as they should be but I think
that like it's more like that we have
many formalisms for studying all of
these questions and there are no you
know like unique choice or or troyes
that would have been selected by the
community as the real one so maybe this
goes back to the previous questions
previous panel of like to have Grand
Challenges and because of that from a
little bit of an outsider perspective it
may look like that like everyone's
pulling in different directions but I
hope that that's not the case and we
read each other's papers and we try to
understand what people are saying I
think it's truly very important that we
are clear about problems that we are
trying to solve
so all they start is the problem
definition this is the first thing that
I try to teach for all my students right
and yeah again it's then it should be
better this is this just like gives you
more clarity and gives the ability to
compare different works and to recognize
whether you're making progress or not so
I cannot just one thing I take the tier
definition and formalism
maybe easier to come up with these
definitions once you have a an actual
problem in front of you and and I'm
saying this because I've realized as a
researcher that I've haven't been
working really much with concrete
problems beyond you know video games and
things like that and I think moving
forward I want to try to think a bit
more about concrete problems the way
that my colleagues in engineering
departments would do and I think when
perhaps if we were to do so a little bit
more the clear formulation for that
thing we're trying to do would be clear
as clear as well so so so I guess my
answer is if maybe we need to wrap in
put a bit of context around the things
we were doing in general well thank you
very much for for your comments and I
really look forward to lots more
exciting reinforcement learning research
in Canada in the next years thank you
[Applause]